hitter responded my angle Candace Owens
communications director for
turning-points USA Monica Crowley senior
columnist for The Washington Times and
Democratic strategist Rochelle Richey
all right Candace are these political
swipes and kind of reworked you know old
stories are they really worth worth the
half of the reported 65 million dollar
advance that michelle obama was paid for
her memoir by crown publishing I think
to the Democrat Party they're definitely
worth it I mean these are the same tired
and baseless accusations that everybody
says when they want to sell books we saw
this from Michael Wolfe we saw this from
amarosa
they're constantly using the president
and trying to feed the divisive rhetoric
that's already out there in the media
but I take great exception to the idea
that our president is tired of baseless
accusation that he's a misogynist
massagin masajid is not a point Sarah
Sanders misogyny does not appoint
Kellyanne Conway massaging is not a
point everybody on his staff that we are
seeing that as being led by women so
it's really ridiculous and it's higher
but it's really unbecoming especially
coming from the former administration to
constantly verbally assault this
president Rochelle it's it's interesting
coming from someone who's such a global
celebrity as Michelle Obama to hear her
sound I would say rather ordinary in her
criticism of the president I mean what
she said about the president without
necessarily mentioning his name I was
what you'd hear on you know one of the
other cable networks any morning noon
and night you can you could pick that
line out of the commentary that you hear
from all the Trump haters on the other
cables so how does that really
distinguish Michelle Obama from any
garden-variety leftist well Laura I
think it's no surprise that I'm probably
the only person on this panel right now
who's really excited to actually read
Michelle Obama's book I think she's an
exceptional woman I think that she
serves as a great example to women all
across the world that our ticket to
success is our brains and not our body
and I think that she's simply telling
her truth I mean the xenophobic
accusations that were hurled at her
husband
we're definitely offensive and as she
mentioned in her book it put her family
at risk and I think she's just being
very candid and very honest I mean this
is not this is one portion of the book
where she's talking about Trump it's not
entirely about Trump so I I don't see
really the problem with her writing this
book and I think that many more first
ladies I'm sure first Lady Melania Trump
will come out with a book and she will
share her personal feelings of what it
was like to be in a Trump White House so
I'm not really sure why there's so much
anger and hatred as far as Michelle
Obama coming out and sharing her truth
it's not it's not it's not an anger
certainly not hatred we have nothing
personally against the first lady and I
think she's extremely impressive as an
individual as a mother as a spokesperson
for what she believes in so I think
she's very impressive we're talking
about something that they decided to
sell this book with Trump trashing is a
cash-in scenario Monica when you trash
Trump and you could say the same thing
about people criticizing Obama early on
in the Obama presidency it might be fair
here but you trash Trump you get a big
advance and but why is that why is that
interesting that's my point it's
interesting to hear about I guess her
growing up and I guess maybe how she met
Barack oh that we've kind of heard those
stories before but just Trump's a racist
Trump's massages Trump's and massages
Trump said okay
I mean then we've been hearing that now
for years right and and it's boring and
predictable and that's why it's so
disappointing to hear it from the former
first lady I mean there used to be a
rule Laura that if you had nothing nice
to say about someone don't say anything
at all and that rule was also supposed
to really extend two former presidents
their wives and others in a president's
inner circle and mr. Obama's
predecessors have abided by that rule
but neither the former president nor the
first lady have and I wonder if she has
some political ambitions of her own
which is why she thinks she can stake
out this ground in attacking the
president but I also think that they
were both of them were so concerned when
President Trump was elected that their
entire legacy was about to go out out
the window
we were told for 80
by the obamas and everyone in their
administration that the new normal was
high unemployment and the loss of
manufacturing jobs an anemic economic
growth and American declined and the
globalist March all of these things were
inevitable president Trump has put the
lie to all of that and so I think what
you're seeing is enormous frustration
and lashing out other part of mrs. Obama
and frankly everybody in the Obama
administration all right I want to play
for you something from Zerlina Maxwell
I'll go to Candace on this and she was
on MSNBC today on this very subject
let's watch I agree with her the fact
that we elected someone who had no
qualifications to be president who was
running against a woman with a laundry
list of qualifications to be President
and instead America or the electoral
chose to give the electoral college to
the person with no experience who happen
to be a man just like all of the other
presidents and so what Michelle Obama is
highlighting is the fact that that in
and of itself is misogynistic and sexist
and perhaps as a country we should take
a moment to reflect on that again women
who voted for Trump are either dumb or
they're just following their husbands
and we're not going to offer any ideas
Candice about how to raise the standard
of living for the average American we're
just gonna call people misogynist racist
xenophobic nativist the old iasts
and all the isms they're all worn out
forget the actual debating of ideas
that's exactly correct and look it
you're right it is frustration it is
fatigue you know they're not offering
anything of substance there's no
ideological debate taking place it has
been proven now okay if you were
apprehensive in the beginning about
Trump and his lack of experience in the
realm of politics but it's now proven
beyond a shadow of a doubt that this
president has been tremendously
successful so at this point it feels a
bit like whining and I think just as
Americans are ready to move on from this
concept of everybody has to be a yzma
they don't think like me you don't elect
somebody because they're a woman you
lexif ID because they're the best person
suited for the job and up against
Hillary Clinton president Trump was a
much stronger candidate he ran a better
campaign and that's why he's sitting in
the Oval Office today
hey Rochelle do you think that the press
has treated Melania in the same way that
they treated Michele
well like no I don't think they have and
I can be honest about that I mean when
we look at how Michelle Obama was
treated she was treated in a very
different way but I think that's because
her husband was also not pushing forward
a very divisive rhetoric in the press
and her husband was not attacking the
press so and this is something Leo
Melania is not innocent in this at all
either when it comes as to this whole
birther issue which she also pedaled for
her husband so yeah no they haven't
treated her fairly but at the same time
I think that they're looking at the the
sort of administration the sort of
rhetoric that is coming from her husband
and is not attractive to them are you
aware of the the polls at the end of the
Obama administration about whether the
country felt like his eight years in
office had United the country are you
aware of those for sure
well what I'm aware of is that 77% of
this country right now and the polls
that came out just before the midterm
elections says that the country feels
that there are more divisive I am I
earned that point I understand that but
what I'm trying to say in Monaca I'm
sure you're aware of this that there was
a wild percentage of Americans who
believe that the Obama presidency was
not a uniting force in America despite
all the promise and the historic nature
of his presidency people felt like the
country was more divided and less United
how and angrier and they said this one
this is not like a Daily Caller poll
okay this is I think it was ap or
Washington Post forgive me for not
having enough the top my head I did it
today on radio but Monica so the the
idea that Trump is the great divisive
factor in America it's not how a lot of
people felt at the end of eight years of
Obama which is why in part they elected
Trump well that's exactly right and what
we saw over eight years with President
Obama is that while he was personally
popular people appreciated the fact that
he was an exceptional character the
first African American president they
were proud of that fact his policies
were wholly unpopular and in some ways
that's the mirror image
Donald Trump where personal he's not so
popular but his policies are incredibly
popular so you know and getting back to
the Melania issue I you know any
Republican first lady is going to be
treated like this Laura it's just you
know a fact of the double standard life
in America unfortunately and it's really
unfair to her but I think Americans by
and large are sick of the double
standard and and that's why I was a
parent yet continuing support for Trump
because he's trying to smash it
well let's invite a parent and Candace
Ramos at a time but look I mean the
bushes did not criticize the Obamas they
didn't that's correct because because
it's respectful and because we had
Benghazi because Obama care was a
cramdown but they also didn't question
whether or not Obama was born in this
country like I don't know how you can
these are I'm gonna finish my it's them
trying to resuscitate their relevancy
because unfortunately every relevant as
president has has laid slaughter to the
Obama legacy and that's what's going on
not at all all right guys thanks so much